i got a very interesting email uh
voicemail rather
about 2024. you can call my voicemail
number
any time of day and many of you do
the number of voicemails we get in the
middle of the night stunning uh here's
one about 2024 2192 david p
is the number hi david um this is
aeroscience shannon i'm calling from
towns michigan
and i was wondering um
the entire trump impeachment scenario
was going on
yes what do you think it means for this
country that
all the evidence that was shown the the
footage of the riot and the breaking of
the capital
and somehow he was still acquitted like
what does that say about this country
um does it worry you um because i'm
really afraid like if he can get away
with something like that
what are we gonna do in 2024 when like a
trump junior runs
in my license office i'm terrified what
do you think it says about this country
and where are we going
thanks yeah one of the most uh
disgusting
i guess we have to call them realities
that we have to accept
uh is that when you look at the
republican vote
to acquit in the senate and then you
look at trump's letter saying
i'm sticking around and we've got a lot
of stuff planned for the next few months
and you see that 64 percent of
republicans in a recent poll
70 of republicans in another recent poll
say if trump created his own party
i would leave the gop and join the trump
party
what you can you have no choice
but to accept that a trump-like figure
could indeed win again in 2024. now
the hope is that if there's a split
between
trump and the republican party that
they do damage to each other and you
could have
a sort of cannibalistic effect where
trump takes some of the republican party
trump or a trumpian candidate maybe
trump jr maybe ivanka
maybe marjorie taylor green who knows
they run and they take a bunch of the
vote and then you've got the republican
vote which is damaged
and then you end up with a situation uh
like the ross pro
situation of the early 90s with a
democrat winning
that that's the ideal scenario now there
are people who will look at that and say
you know the math could work out
differently
and i understand that um but
if 64 of the country is willing to
follow trump we all have to recognize
that that is exactly the concern
with not ridding ourselves of this
problem
right away and how could we when tens of
millions of people continue to support
it so yeah the caller is absolutely
right
in her concern we have a great bonus
show today we are going to talk about
you know i get emails all the time from
people
from from the trolls david why won't you
ever talk about what's going on with
andrew cuomo in new york
because andrew cuomo doesn't seem to be
managing a lot of things correctly and
there's a lot of things coming out
we've been covering it from the
beginning and we will again cover
how the covet 19 story is getting even
worse
for democratic new york governor andrew
cuomo that's on today's
bonus show also on the bonus show the
boeing 737 max
is flying again and it's very quietly
flying again
and we're going to talk about how
airlines have brought it back because it
has been cleared
but they're not advertising it and it's
obvious why
lots of people still aren't interested
if they are going back to flying at this
point during the pandemic
they're not interested in flying on the
737 max but it is back and i'm going to
i have a kind of a personal story about
this myself we will also talk about how
the supreme court has stayed
the execution of an alabama inmate who
has requested a pastor's presence
the details are very interesting and we
will discuss that
and more on today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com you can use the coupon
code if you so please to get a discount
the coupon code is better21 you can also
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a patron
at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i will see you on the
bonus show sadly
if you don't have access to the bonus
show we will meet again tomorrow
see you then